hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast 5 steps for publication
quality immunohistochemistry
images presented by Jason Kilgore
technical application scientist thermal
official scientific I'm Christina
Roberts and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by lab roads
and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information on our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education tab located at the
top right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
I would now like to introduce our
presenter Jayson Kilgore technical
application scientist
Thermo Fisher Scientific Jason has
worked with thermo Fisher Scientific
since 1999 his initial work in research
and development focused on the
development of dyes and techniques
primarily used for microscopy and
imaging of cultured cell and tissue
section samples Jason's experience also
included leading an R&D group that
produced 36 new products and optimized
many others in his current role as a
member of the technical support team for
cellular analysis in a V Trojan Evo S
cell imaging systems
Jason helps thousands of researchers a
year to develop and optimize their
protocols using cell imaging and
analysis agent kits and instruments
prior to coming to Thermo Fisher
Scientific
Jason earned a Bachelor of Arts in
biology at Hendel college and they
masters of science of biology at Central
Michigan University welcome Jason you
may now begin your presentation
hi thank you very much for attending
today's webinar on immunohistochemistry
my name is Jason Kilgore I'm a thermo
Fisher Scientific I've been here since
1999 when we were initially molecular
probes incorporated I worked in R&D for
many years and including leading a group
and for the last nine to ten years I've
been in technical support helping
researchers like you many of the
presentation images today
are images that I took although I do
have some from collaborators as well and
many of them are products that I helped
develop in R&D so hopefully this will
prove very useful for you today we're
going to talk about immunohistochemistry
that is antibody labeling of tissues for
imaging and microscopy I should mention
also that there are a number of web
links in this presentation feel free to
come back to the recording so you can
see those in time that you have to
follow up with them the recording will
also be available later if you should
wish to come back and listen to it or
have a colleague listen to it this
presentation is going to be presented in
five parts the so-called five steps
covered in the webinar the first part
will be to give you helpful hints and
tricks and troubleshooting related to
preparing your samples such as mounting
fixation deep paraffin ization then
we'll go on to antigen retrieval or
antigen and masking then we'll talk
about blocking the background and the
many different methods for that the
fourth part will be detecting the target
that's the meat of the presentation if
you will in terms of the primary and
secondary label steps and then finally
some information on how to visualize
your samples mainly with microscopy and
analysis and software so basically this
presentation goes from the beginning to
the end of your
immunohistochemistry experience let's go
into part one or step one preparing your
sample
there are many different protocols for
preparing your tissues but generally
speaking the most common are either
paraffin processing or cryo section
processing with paraffin processing you
fix your tissue after you've extracted
it from the animals and then you go on
to move it through a dehydration series
usually an ethanol from water at zero
percent ethanol up through to a hundred
percent then into another solvent such
as xylene or limonene sometimes toluene
and then embedding into para Plast which
is a plastic paraffin mix or histo Plast
which is our version of it the embedding
process is in is where your tissue is
actually embedded in the paraffin and
this paraffin block can be stored
long-term even at room temperature until
you're ready to section it once you're
rated is section of then you would put
it on a microtome and section and mount
it on a slide
another process is to do cryo section or
cryogenic processing this is where you
take your tissue fix it and then put it
through a graded sucrose series up to
one hundred percent sucrose and then
into a embedding medium the most common
is Oct we also sell Meg 50 medium and
this is a medium that solution at room
temperature but upon freezing it at
minus 20 or in liquid nitrogen or
something it will freeze into a solid
block you can then store those blocks
for sometimes years at minus 20 or
better yet minus 80 degrees until you're
ready to section it at which point
you'll take that block put it into a
cryo to cryo stat which is like a
microtome but but it's frozen and the
crowd that has blades that will section
the tissue into thin sections that you
can then mount onto a slide there are a
few other mic methodologies out there
such as vibra tone sections or fresh
frozen and I'm not really going to touch
on that in
presentation also more common these days
our hole mounts or even spheroid imaging
or 3d cell culture imaging we have a
great web resource listed here at thermo
Fisher comm slash histology that talks
about a number of these different
preparation methods
okay once you've taken your tissue and
sent it through that preparation process
and embedded and then sectioned you now
have slides with sections on them but at
the beginning of that process sorry is
the fixation that's where you take your
tissue and you extract it and you fix it
with some sort of method the most common
method is cross-linking with aldehydes
for instance formaldehyde or
glutaraldehyde formaldehyde is the most
common both of these form methylene
bridges that cross-linked proteins
together and by cross leaking these
proteins you preserve the morphology of
your tissue as well as preserving the
antigen of interest that you're
detecting with your antibody the back
the problem with this though is
sometimes you can over fix which can
lead to brittle tissue in some tissue
types and also you can cause masking of
antigen binding sites and increased
autofluorescence and I'll talk a little
bit more about those issues later but
still formaldehyde is the most commonly
used
there are also fixation techniques that
are coagulating this is using a solvent
such as methanol ethanol or acetone to
coagulate the proteins of interest
because it doesn't cross-linked the
proteins this can preserve the
antigenicity of your proteins apart that
you're targeting and this can permeable
eyes your sample as well this is great
if you're going for very hard to reach
antigens like in the nuclear
compartments however because it doesn't
cross-linked proteins can sometimes lead
to loss of morphology disruption of the
morphology especially in some fragile
tissues and this is a big part of some
artifacts from sectioning the tissues
with your cryo stat or microtome as well
and by solubilizing those membranes it
can also cause loss of membrane antigens
too so it's a very good idea to talk to
the source of your antibody
primary antibody and ask them which
fixation technique they recommend for
that particular antibody and antigen
now when you fix your sample it
cross-links the proteins in place and
this is great because it preserves the
antigen in its location be aware though
that some reagents such as some organic
dyes may be retained with fixation but
not technically cross-linked in place
leading to an off rate where that the
dye can be lost over time and I show an
example of that on the right-hand side
of some organic dyes that when stored at
a hot temperature 37 degrees for 14 days
have come off the tissue leading to
lower specific staining also sometimes
it's a good idea to post fix so you
fixed your sample you do your antibody
labeling then you come in with
formaldehyde again this will cross link
the antibodies in place so that they
don't have this off rate leading to
lower specific signal we sell a fixation
permeabilization kit that you see listed
here now here at Thermo Fisher
Scientific it's a we're a very large
company that that extends to the full
breadth of biological research including
materials sold for these processing
techniques we saw the cryo stats and
microtones we sell all the accessories
we even sell full embedding workstations
and tissue processors as well so that
entire process can be automated in those
tissue processors here's a listing of a
few of those products but again you can
go to the histology landing page to link
to many of these now be aware that there
can be a number of different artifacts
from your sectioning technique and
fixation technique I show some examples
here probably the most common is that
the tissue has folds it isn't level II
put on to the slide leading to folds in
it that can lead to these artifacts that
you see here or bubbles under the tissue
so it's important to have a very good
technique when you section and lay the
tissue down on the
lines so that you don't tear it or fold
it
you
another common obstacle that you face in
microscopy especially with fluorescent
dyes is autofluorescence
autofluorescence is the native
fluorescent background inherent in the
tissue so if you're trying to detect
with a fluorescent secondary antibody
for instance there's a background there
that you have to overcome and it's
important that you don't mistake this
for your specific signal not all tissue
flores's and all backgrounds for
autofluorescence so it's very important
to have a control with no dye on it to
see what that background fluorescence is
and where it's expressing this
background fluorescence can be worse
with aldehyde fixation so you don't want
to over fix glutaraldehyde in particular
is quite bad also paraffin sections are
very bad for autofluorescence so usually
for fluorescent imaging it's important
to go to cryo sections if possible
usually this Auto fluorescence is very
broad spectrum so you'll see it in at
least in the green and red and sometimes
in the blue far red is a good idea if
you want to overcome it as well how do
you deal with Auto fluorescence when you
have it
well I highly recommend doing chemical
treatments sodium borohydride is a
powder you can find from chemical
companies like sigma-aldrich for
instance and we may sell it on other
parts of our company as well and this is
where you treat your tissue after you've
rehydrated it so you have your tissue on
your slides you rehydrate into PBS and
then you treat it with three times ten
minutes of very freshly made immediately
before use of one MIG per mil sodium
borohydride in PBS and as you can see
here in this example the red
autofluorescence was knocked down almost
to background here by treating it in
this method the idea here is that it's
breaking down those cross-linking --zz
from the aldehyde fixation that's
leading to the auto fluorescence
another way you can deal with
autofluorescence is to amplify your
signal over it so for instance here I
can show on the left and image of a
mouse cerebellum labeled with a primary
and secondary antibody and the secondary
is labeled with Alexa fluor 488 which is
a green fluorescent dye and
unfortunately there was a lot of green
autofluorescence so you don't see these
Bergmann glia those nice striations
there but if you amplify the signal by
instead using an H R P or horseradish
peroxidase labeled secondary antibody
and then detect the h RP with a 488 tear
amide signal amplification you can see
now you have a much better much stronger
signal requiring a lower exposure time
and now it's so so much more intense
than the background you don't see that
autofluorescence we sell our Tara might
super boost kits that can help with this
and another final way you can deal with
Auto fluorescence is through software
manipulation there are some special
spectral deconvolution systems out there
that you can use that will do this
automatically for you or you can use
your imaging software where you collect
an image in your specific wavelength
like the green here and you can see
little arrows which are the specific
signals of the proliferating cells in
this tissue but there's a lot of green
autofluorescence luckily the auto
fluorescence is very broad wavelength so
if you don't have any specific labels in
your red wavelength you can switch over
and take an image from that and then use
your imaging software to subtract the
red image from your green leaving the
image down in the lower right where now
you can only see the specific spots
indicated by those white arrows
our celeste imaging software can do that
for you by the way
okay once you've rehydrated your sample
and dealt with the autofluorescence now
you need to permeable eyes your sample
now paraffin sections go through solvent
washes so they're already delivered ated
the cells and tissue are our permeable
eyes by those solvents so it's not as
necessary for paraffin sections but for
prions and hole mounts it's very
important that you do a permeabilization
the most common way is to use a
detergent such as triton x-100
or alcohols a detergent will poke holes
by breaking down that membrane and by
basically poking holes in the membrane
it allows large molecules like your
primary and secondary antibodies to
diffuse down into the cells and attach
to the antigens of interest usually a
point one or point two percent triton
for sixty minutes is sufficient
I also recommend including that
detergent in every wash and incubation
throughout the protocol just to make
sure you hit it hard however there are a
few people out there some researchers
who use solvents such as acetone this.d
lipid eise's the membrane and really
breaks it down so that you have easy
entrance of the antibodies but you can
overdo it so be careful the acetone has
to be pre chilled at minus 20 degrees
and only wash your tissues for a short
time in it such as maybe 10 to 20
minutes going too long can really
disturb the morphology of your tissue we
felt write an X 100 and other detergents
as well
after you've permeable eyes your sample
then we move on to step two which is the
antigen retrieval antigen retrieval also
called epitope retrieval or antigen
unmasking is a means by which you can
reveal the antigen binding sites of your
protein of interest your antigen which
can sometimes be hidden by cross-linking
with those aldehydes the most typical
method is to use heat induced antigen
retrieval where you expose it to a high
heat but sometimes proteolytic digestion
or both can be used notice that we have
a very good landing page for antigen
retrieval so when you do a heat induced
antigen retrieval which is the most
common method this is where you heat the
sample by some method and maybe adjust
the pH either as a low pH or high pH
depending upon the antibody the most
typical ways to do the heat induction
are either with a double boiler on a
heat plate where you take your your
slides with tissue and lower it into the
hot solution or with a lab grade
microwave or with little devices there
are basically little pressure cookers
that you put your sample in a few people
even use other heating instruments such
as autoclaves
to heat the sample but anyways you heat
at a very high degree up near the
boiling point of water up around 100
degrees Celsius some antibodies require
a low pH such as a citrate buffer others
require high pH so it's important to
talk to the source of your primary
antibody to see if it needs antigen
retrieval and if so which kind has been
tested on it if you label with your
primary antibody without antigen
retrieval and you don't see a good
signal it may be that you need an AR
method and so you might try a few
different types
we sell some antigen retrieval solutions
as I mentioned or listed on that
previous slide here's an example where
we tested heat-induced antigen retrieval
with the primary antibody heating it up
probably in a pressure cooker system and
we tried different PHS so you can see
that you need at least a pH of 8 in that
to get a good signal these were the only
images I could find from our company but
some antibodies have an even bigger
difference some you won't even see an
antigen expression at all here in the
brown is a DA B detection and the Brown
is your specific signal from the primary
antibody another way other than heat is
to use proteolytic digestion this is
where you use proneness or pepsin
proteinase k this this breaks down the
protein structure around your antigen
allowing your antibody to detect the
antigen of interest some antibodies
require this instead of heat heat
induced antigen retrieval it's not as
common but it is something that you can
find in the literature pretty easily you
have to be careful though because if you
go too long you can damage your tissue
morphology and maybe even damage the
antigen itself that you're trying to
detect so you definitely have to
optimize this step very carefully
we sell a number as you can see here a
number of different proteolytic
digestion solutions
some other notes an Shin retrieval for
whatever reason is more commonly used on
paraffin sections but I've needed it on
prow sections as well and even sells on
cover slips so it's not just limited to
paraffin we sell a a system here the lab
vision system which does a deep paraffin
ization and heat induced epitope
retrieval solution can we sell many
products related to that
okay on to step three here we're going
to talk about the blocking conditions
what is blocking blocking is where
you're you're treating the tissue in a
way that your primary and secondary
antibody are not going to give you a
nonspecific signal so you're making sure
that it goes to the target of interest
the most common sort of blocking that
you hear about is protein blocking
because primary and secondary antibodies
will bind to their protein of interest
but sometimes other proteins in the
milieu of your tissue
the most common blocking techniques are
to use bovine serum albumin or BSA or
serum like normal goat serum for
instance or a combination of those two
there's also a number of commercial
blocking agents we sell blockade
solution for instance I actually helped
develop blockade for this usage and if
you use BSA and NGS I recommend or maybe
a 6% BSA and five to ten percent serum
as a good combination our blockade
solution comes at a 1x solution so you
can put it right on your tissue and it
works as well and often better than BSA
or serum or other home brew remedies you
can also make your primary and secondary
antibodies in blockade so it's great and
you can see some data here where it's
knocked down the background binding on
these cerebellum sections almost to the
autofluorescence level and you can see
some catalog numbers here to also the e
bioscience side of our company sells
some protein blocking solutions that are
very good now a form of blocking that
isn't commonly known as dye charge
blocking this is where negatively
charged eyes like the alexa fluor dyes
will be not specifically attracted to
positively charged areas on the tissue
in cultured cells as as nuclei and
mitochondria in cerebellum like you see
images here it's the white matter in
these cryo
affections and so protein blocking will
not stop this instead you need to use
our image it FX signal enhancer solution
it enhances a signal in the sense that
it knocks down the nonspecific binding
this blocks those positively charged
areas and it's a dropper bottle solution
and then when you come in with your
negatively charged dyes you don't see
that binding so you do your protein
blocking first and then you would come
in and drop this solution onto it for
maybe thirty minutes on to your section
and it will block that binding then you
can go on to further steps
additionally there can be blocking for
endogenous enzymes so for instance if
you come in with your primary antibody a
secondary antibody that has biotin on it
and then detect the biotin with a
streptavidin with a dye conjugate on it
that streptavidin will not only bind to
the biotin on your antibody but it will
also bind to endogenous biotin in your
tissues biotin for instance is found
endogenously in mitochondria so it's
important to block this so this step
comes in after your your protein
blocking we have a kit where you just
drop on a couple of dropper bottle
solutions after your protein blocking
and maybe your image at FX signal
enhancer and this will block the
endogenous button so that later you can
come in and you won't detect it with
your streptavidin also it's very common
to use h RP or horseradish peroxidase
labeled secondaries and then detect that
with diamino benzidine or at aramide
superboost kit or some other kits and
tissue in particular is very bad for
endogenous peroxidases so you'll want to
block with h2 o2 hydrogen peroxide prior
to going on to your primary solution and
this will knock down the proxy basis or
if you're detecting with a with a
alkaline phosphatase labeled secondary
it's important to block the endogenous
phosphatases with lava misil before you
go on to detect it we have this Web
resource here for endogenous blocking
methods okay onto step 4
detecting your target when we talk about
immunohistochemistry antibody detection
this is the part that people think of
the most your primary and secondary
antibody label steps so you've blocked
your sample you've permeable eyes dit
now you go on to your primary antibody
this is where a an antibody has been
grown in a host
animal and then packaged so you get a
vial of it and then you dilute it down
to maybe five to ten micrograms per
milliliter into your blocking buffer and
label your tissue a typical label will
be several hours to overnight at four
degrees to detect your specific signal
this is just the primary antibody not
the actual detection part which is your
secondary antibody usually now how do
you choose a primary antibody well of
course you want to make sure it's grown
against the antigen of interest and you
want to go with a company that has good
products like us if I may say so and
consider the clone of your antibody some
clones are better than others and
sometimes when you search for an
antibody like on our antibody selection
tool as you see down below a link for it
there will be two or three different
clones sometimes in the literature it'll
say one clone or another so you can go
with that monoclonal versus polyclonal
monoclonal will be specific to like IgG
whereas polyclonal especially in rabbits
polyclonal isn't specific to one iso
type or another
make sure your antibody is within its
stability period so most of our
antibodies are guaranteed for several
months if stored correctly once your
antibody gets to a year or more I would
be very concerned about its stability
even if stored at minus 20 so be careful
about that
check that the antibody is recommended
for immunohistochemistry some antibodies
are only validated for Western blot
analysis for instance or flow cytometry
and those aren't always good for a very
complex system like a tissue section so
make sure it's validated for
immunohistochemistry or maybe immuno
Saito chemistry or ICC
which is labeling of cells in culture
and finally and very importantly
consider the host species and isotype
that you're choosing so that it can be
matched with your secondary antibody so
for instance if you have a mouse tissue
you you don't want to use a mouse
primary because then you your secondary
will detect the endogenous IgG and your
tissue as well as your primary there are
kids that can overcome this if necessary
but if I had a mouse tissue ad for
instance go with probably a rabbit
primary antibody and then I could come
in within maybe a donkey anti rabbit
secondary it's important to make that
connection
okay how can it go bad so sometimes an
antibody maybe it's degraded or maybe
it's not the right clone and you don't
get specific signal here's an example on
the left of good staining of a paraffin
section the blue there is hematoxylin
for nuclei and the brown is your
specific signal for the antigen of
interest detected with diamino benzidine
or DA B and you can see on the left you
have good specific staining in the
region of these tonsils that you want
whereas in the right you see brown
labeling all over the background which
is nonspecific also the concentration
has to be very carefully type rated so
if you haven't used a primary antibody
before it's good to try a number a
number of different concentrations and
label time to get just the right
expression so for instance here you can
see on the left some cells that were
labeled with too much antibody and and
so this was an anti tubulin so you don't
see the nice fine tubulin structures and
cut instead you have this mass around
the nuclear region on the right hand
side you can see they the right
concentration five micrograms per mil in
this case where you get good detection
of those fibers without blowing it out
also as I mentioned is antigen retrieval
needed if you have too little of a
signal it could indicate that you need
an AR method to express the antigen of
site or maybe that may be the if you're
not getting a signal maybe the primary
is degraded for instance here's some
examples where the primary antibody was
degraded on the left are some cells
where I was detecting Golgi bodies and
in the upper left you can see there is a
lot of background in the nucleus and off
cell and on cell background a new
antibody cleared that up on the right
was an antibody that instead of giving
nice fibers you see a sort of pearls on
a string look to the fibers
and that's because it was just degraded
so fresh antibody is very important okay
so once you've labeled with your primary
antibody usually overnight at 4 degrees
you'll wash and then you'll come in with
a secondary antibody of choice usually
the secondary antibody you'll label for
maybe a couple hours two to four hours
at room temperature and it's labeled
typically with a dye like low the alexa
fluor dyes or sometimes a biotin or an
enzyme again as with the primary
antibodies go with a trusted company and
go with the protocol that that company
recommends make sure it's in its
stability period and is fairly fresh
within a year at the very longest make
sure it's got the correct host and
target so if I have a rabbit primary now
I want an anti rabbit secondary to
detect it and as I mentioned you have to
choose whether you want to die or an
enzyme we have a great selection tool as
you can see a link down below where you
can go to choose an antibody of interest
and there's a number of different types
of secondary antibodies for instance
whole IgG s are the most common because
they give you the strongest signal
they're relatively inexpensive but they
can have some cross reactivity what do I
mean by cross reactivity well for
instance if you have a tissue section
with two different antigens you're
wanting to detect one engine you want to
detect with a mouse primary one with the
say a rabbit primary you then come in
with a secondary against the mouse and
rabbit primaries but you don't want your
anti Mouse to detect your rabbit that's
cross labeling or cross reactivity and
you don't want your anti rabbit to
detect your mouse so it's important when
you buy the antibodies if you're doing
multicolor labeling that you check the
cross reactivity x' for
the company make sure you're for
instance anti-mouse secondary has been
cross adsorbed against a rabbit and vice
versa
FAT FAT two fragments are much more
specific to the FC receptors on the
primary antibody of target but you have
a lower degree of labeling of dyes so
it's not as strong of a signal if you're
doing multiple primaries on the same
tissue it's a very good idea to have
highly cross adsorbed secondaries that
have been cross adsorbed against
multiple different species so you don't
have that cross reactivity problem and
finally sometimes we sell subtype
specific antibodies so for instance if
you have two different mouths primaries
on the same tissue one can be an IgG one
isotype and the other can be an IgG 2a
isotype and if you have subtype specific
antibodies against IgG one mouse or IgG
- a mouse you can use them in the same
label step and not have to worry about
cross labeling
you
and again you have to optimize your
labeling time and concentration as I
mentioned two to four hours at room
temperature is typical a concentration
might be somewhere around five
micrograms per mil and again in a
blocking solution usually bovine serum
albumin is fine or in our blockade
blocking solution here on the right you
can see a DEA be labeled section in
brown where the brown is your specific
labeling always optimize now the I'm
talking about research use in this
presentation clinical clinical analyses
you can't optimize because it's already
been pre optimized so be aware that if
you're doing clinical analysis you have
to stick very carefully to a prescribed
protocol
now da B which gives you that Brown
deposition this is where you have a
primary antibody then you come in with a
secondary antibody that has horseradish
peroxidase or HRP and then you do a
chemical detection which precipitates
Brown anywhere that the HRP is localized
however you still have to optimize label
time and concentration so on the left
here is an example of mouth ileum that
was not detected with the right
concentration label time leading to low
signal and on the right here is now too
long of a DEA be detections now you have
brown everywhere so with the proper
development you can get a very specific
labeling on the antigen receptors of
interest for instance here and breast
cancer a section how do you choose the
dye of interest sometimes you'll go with
a chroma genic dye like da B this is
where you use transmitted light
microscopy to see it or you'll go with a
fluorescent dye like alexa fluor 488
where you use a fluorescent microscope
to see it how do you choose people often
have in in their labs specific protocols
that they use and it's fine to keep
following those but I recommend being
open to one or the other method and
maybe trying both for instance with
fluorescent detection you can get more
labels on your tissue because you're now
detecting only within a very specific
wavelength green or red or far red so
now you can get as many as four I've
done is me as six different labels on
the same tissue sections however now you
have to deal with photo bleaching
effects and I'll talk more about that in
a minute
and maybe it's got more of an off rate
than you do with chroma genic slides
whereas chroma genic slides like da B
and other chroma genic dyes you mount in
a solvent based mountain ting can save
the slide for years often and it's fine
for that so their drawbacks T and pros
and cons for each of these
now sometimes you don't want to do a
direct detection sometimes instead you
want to do an amplification technique
this is where you amplify your signal
over background this is very important
if you're detecting low expressing
antigens or if you're trying to overcome
autofluorescence so with a direct label
conjugate this is a primary antibody
that has a dye on it you only get it
you know maybe two dye molecules per
primary and that's not sufficient for
tissue usually sometimes in cell
detection especially a flow cytometry
which is more sensitive it's fine now
most typically we go with a typical
secondary antibody with a dye on it but
again if you need amplification you
might want to go to a streptavidin
biotin this is where your secondary
antibody with a biotin elated and you
can go on to that with a streptavidin
detection and this will give you twenty
to forty dyes per target that's often
sufficient however sometimes there are
very low expression targets so now you
want to go to HR P Tyr amide detection
or da B and this is where it deposits a
with Tera minds that deposits a
fluorescent substrate around the site of
a horseradish peroxidase labeled
secondary and this is a huge
amplification 120 to 200 dyes per target
which is great now you get a very nice
strong signal but why would you not want
to use these for instance well here's
some examples so you have to scale it to
the amplification or abundance of your
target so in a high abundance antigen
like tubulin for instance on the top row
this this antigen is very commonly
expressed in cells with a large amount
so a direct detection or typical
secondary detection is fine you can see
some nice specific fibers there but if
you go with Tera might signal
amplification now you blow it out right
you get much too much expression you
lose the nice fine
liber expression there and it's very
very bright so bright even that you
might have to throw in neutral density
filters on your microscope you don't
want all that but if you're going with a
low abundance target like catenin on the
lower panel now you need to amplify your
signal in order to see the few proteins
that are expressed there a direct
conjugate is not nearly good enough
a typical go-to anti-mouse secondary
here shows a specific signal but you're
seeing some background there too so now
if you amplify with Tera might signal
amplification now you see a nice bright
specific signal that's adjusted over the
background
you
use the dye of interest if you're going
with fluorescents well you want to make
sure that you know which filters or
wavelengths you have on your imaging
system and match dyes to those and you
want to make sure that if you're doing
multiple different colors on the same
tissue that the dyes are spectrally
seperated from each other we have a very
useful tool online called the spectra
viewer and you can see a link here and
this is where you can list numerous
different dyes all together and see how
they their wavelengths overlap you can
even put your excitation and emission
filters or laser lines into those tabs
and it will display it so that you can
tell whether or not the dye of interest
overlaps with your filters very nicely
pretty much all of our dyes are in this
spectra viewer
one problem that with the detection
method is bleed-through so for instance
let's say you have two different dyes on
your tissue a green dye like alexa fluor
488 and an orange red dye in the side
three wavelengths like alexa fluor 555
here's an image that was taken in the
green filter with alexa fluor so alexa
fluor 488 the specific signal in the 488
is that punctate spot those spots which
are peroxisomes but now in the green
filter you're seeing these striations
there which is actually the alexa fluor
555 which was so bright that now you can
see it in the green filter what do you
do about that well you can reduce your
555 labeling intensity by reducing the
label time or concentration so it's not
so bright and bleeding through or you
can choose not to use the 555 and go
with a dye that's farther separated like
Texas red or alexa fluor 594 or on into
the far red dyes and now it's not likely
to bleed through into your green Channel
you can also use imaging software
special spectral deconvolution systems
to separate the signals
controls are very important so let me
spend a moment on that so I mentioned
earlier autofluorescence controls this
is where you take your tissue you wash
it and permeable eyes it and mount it as
you would know the other sections that
you don't have primary antibody or
secondary antibody all you want to see
is how bad is your background
autofluorescence without any dye present
if it's very high then you do your
sodium borohydride washes but hopefully
there's no signal also you want a no
primary control this is where you omit
your primary antibody but you still use
your secondary antibody detection this
will check to see if you see any
background just from your secondary
antibody detection method if you don't
you're good to go
if you do see background then you might
want to go in and readjust your
secondary label time or maybe have
better blocking solution more stringent
blocking or maybe your antibody is
degraded finally if you're doing
multiple colors on the same tissue do a
cross labeling control this is where you
have only a single color so let's say
you're wanting to use a mouse and rabbit
secondary on the same section you'll go
with only one sojust Mouse primary but
instead of detecting with your anti
Mouse secondary you detect with your
anti rabbit secondary to see if it cross
labels hopefully it won't and vice versa
you also have one with your rabbit
primary and you come in with the anti
Mouse secondary and hopefully you won't
see binding but it's important when you
start doing a series of assays that you
check this here's an example with an O
primary control so on the Left we
omitted the primary antibody but still
detected with an HR P secondary and da B
detection and hematoxylin four nuclei
whereas on the in the middle there you
can see a picture where the brown is
your specific da B this is where we did
use the primary antibody so now you can
see you're getting nice
specific labeling with almost no
background
finally after you do your primary and
secondary antibodies now you can counter
stain your sections the most common is
do a nuclear detection so in
fluorescence you might detect with Dappy
your Hoechst in the blue to label the
nuclei in chroma genic sections you
might label with hematoxylin and eosin
hematoxylin is blue or purple II nuclei
eosin gives you this light purple or
reddish color for this cytoplasm in
fluorescence also there's a number of
different counter stains for instance
here in the magenta color is six alexa
fluor six four seven phalloidin which
labels the actin of the microvilli in
this intestine section very pretty
I love phalloidin it's a toxic protein
found in a deadly mushroom but it sure
detects acting great finally after
you've done your your detection or your
counter stains now you want to mount
your sample and detect it on your
microscopes and do a software analysis
of it so let's talk about mounting
medium so after you've done your
labeling you have to put a cover slip on
usually and that cover slip has to have
a solution underneath it that's your
mounting medium for fluorescent samples
you want to make sure that there's a an
anti fade present an anti fade mounting
medium will slow the photo bleaching and
I'll talk about that again in the next
slide if you want to just visualize your
sample under the microscope and then
throw away your slide you want a non
curing or liquidy mounting medium that
does not harden such as our slow fade
diamond anti-fade mountains if you want
it to if you want to archive your slides
for imaging later days two weeks later
or even months you want a hardening or
curing mountain for fluorescent samples
I recommend our prolonged diamond ante
fade mountains or prolonged glass for
chroma genex slides you'll often go with
cytosine sixty or histone mount
for instance our DPX which hardened very
hard you have to chip it off if you
wanted to remove it
whatever mountain you choose make sure
it has a very good refractive index
close to glass like the glass used in
your cover slip and your objective lens
usually around 1.5 to for the best
resolution this will ensure that you
have good resolution especially at the
high magnification objectives if you're
doing fluorescence make sure your
mountain does not itself Auto
fluorescent to give background
photo bleaching so if you have a
fluorescent sample when you shine light
on it using your microscope you'll
notice that the dye starts to go dim
over time as you're looking at it that's
photo bleaching it's a it's a photo
physical effect on the structure of the
dye causing destruction of the dye
structure and so it stops fluorescing
you can use anti fade mounting mediums
like prolong gold and prolong diamond
prolong glass these have components in
it that are anti oxidants and free
radical scavengers that can vastly slow
this photo bleaching effect I highly
recommend you use an anti fade mounting
medium for any fluorescent detection we
have a web resource down there at thermo
Fisher comm slash anti fades to help
with that
also we've recently reintroduced
prolonged blasts so if you have
especially if you have very thick
samples the refractive index is very
critical in order to image deep into the
tissue so with prolonged glass we've
demonstrated you can image 70 or even a
hundred micron thick samples and still
detect the signal down deep inside with
very good resolution compared for
instance to a competitor of ours here
where you can't see so far a huge
improvement in depth of detection hole
mounts very thick samples and spheroids
for instance are becoming much more
common now so this is becoming a more
important product here for instance you
can see some images of spheroids labeled
with a couple of our dyes cell rocks
deep red might attract or orange and
Hearst for nuclei that have been imaged
as deep as 100 microns with our
prolonged glass ok let's talk about the
instrument platforms typically you'll
want to use a microscope there's a lot
of different kinds out there the most
common is a wide field microscope either
inverted like our FL auto and FL auto 2
that you see here on our evos product
line but there's a lot of different
microscope companies out there wide
field means that you don't have any
specialized techniques to limit just
your plane of view but there's also
confocal microscopes which use optical
properties to image only a thin section
through your tissue at a time to cut out
extraneous light above and below where
you're wanting to image
there's also multiphoton systems and
light sheet microscopy systems so
there's a lot of different systems out
there but whatever system you use there
are some important hardware concerns
always make sure everything is clean you
know
use clean slides and clean cover slips
without debris on them make sure your
objective lens lenses are cleaned
regularly and professor
generally and choose your objective
lenses wisely with the right objective
magnification numerical aperture align
your light source so with us with our
Evo systems we use an LED light cube
which has the light source built into it
so there's nothing to align which is
marvelous but a lot of typical systems
out there will use a mercury bulb for
instance that has to be carefully
aligned so it's in the centre of your
view and adjusted so that's uniform in
intensity our systems don't need that
also the condensers if you're doing
transmitted light you have to make sure
that your condenser is aligned so it
gives nice centered and uniform
illumination again our Evo systems
there's no alignment necessary for that
also make sure that you have the right
filter sets or like cubes for your diet
I mentioned the spectra viewer earlier
so here you can see an example in the
middle of typical like cubes used in
typical imaging microscopes for
fluorescent imaging re vo's microscopes
use special light cubes that you see on
the right which has everything built
into it including the light source
you
on the left here you can see an example
of an image where the light source was
not carefully uniform and centered so
you see it's brighter on the left and on
the right in the middle is an example of
an objective lens that has not been
cleaned well you can see little specks
in the center there of debris that's on
the lens it's quite common in
microscopes that if people are doing hi
Maggie mijung that they accidentally get
immersion oil on non immersion oil
lenses which can be difficult to clean
so talk to your image facilitator to
make sure that it's cleaned correctly if
you accidentally drag an immersion oil
in a non immersion oil lens also in this
image you can see the objective is
butting up against the stage which can
damage the objective so you have to look
for damage to be very careful by the way
here's a good link to our Evo's
microscope systems just contact us if
you're interested in those systems
remember proper Hardware gives you
efficient detection what's the point in
going through all that protocol to label
if you're not going to have the best
hardware to detect it alright once
you've taken your image well when you
when you have your microscope remember
that you're imaging you have to have
special imaging software to capture it
with your camera system and you have to
optimize those image settings very
carefully namely the exposure time that
you're detecting the gain setting on
your camera the light intensity if
that's adjustable as it is with our Evo
system with confocal microscopes there's
a number of other factors you have to
take into consideration like your laser
intensity the rastering back and forth
on your sample the pinhole size and just
taking the image isn't enough you also
have to think about how you're saving
your image if you if you have a JPEG
format for instance remember it
compresses the image but it also
preserves and 8-bits the color as well
as maybe a scale bar or other
annotations but if you're doing
quantitative
analysis where you're comparing the
intensity between images you want to
save as a 16-bit usually 16-bit TIFF
image which is black and white doesn't
save the color or scale bars but this is
important because that that gives you
the full dynamic range of the camera at
16 bits so you can more carefully
compare the quantitative relative
fluorescence between the images here's
an example screenshot from our Evo's FL
auto 2 imaging system and the software
used and you can see some little bars on
that lower right that you can adjust the
light intensity exposure and gain
settings as well as the focus this image
here is of a kidney section labeled with
Alexa fluor 488 and it's pretty dim so I
would say this is too dim you can adjust
the lighting but now the light and
exposure time are too high
you can see you're saturating the signal
matter-of-fact the software will color
the saturated pixels blue so you want to
back off on that exposure time to
something like this this is an optimized
image so there's little to no saturated
pixels or it's sub saturation this is
where you want to be as well as good
focus here's an example of some cells
that I took which are not a good image
you can see that the cells are not
centered in the image the green
wavelength you can't really pick out
very well because it's too low of an
exposure time or gain setting the red is
a Texas red for mitochondria and it's
too bright too long of an exposure time
saturating the pixels and there's a bit
of blue background maybe it's a little
hard for you to see here whereas if I
optimize all that now you can see a much
better section or image here where the
actin is nice and bright and the green
the mitochondria are not too bright and
I've adjusted the gain so that the Dappy
signal and the nuclei is not too much in
the background
remember optimize settings gives you
accurate data
once you've taken your images now you
want to go to image analysis software
not acquisition software but analysis
software image J for instance is a
freeware out there but it can be a
little bit difficult to use it's not
very user friendly we offer here at
Thermo Fisher Scientific the Celeste
imaging software which is combated
compatible with our evos line of
microscopes and you can see here a three
color image where each of the three
colors is in black and white blue green
and red and I've merged them in the
lower right you can also adjust here you
can see in the red box the contrast and
gamma and brightness of the image and
with image analysis software now you can
analyze your images the most typical way
to analyze to compare intensities
between sections or sorry images is to
use a region of interest here you can
see in yellow some regions that I've
drawn on the cells for this tubulin
labeling sorry actin labeling and a
circle in the background so that I can
subtract the background fluorescence
from the specific fluorescence another
way to detect or measure your cells is
with thresholded a certain range of
intensities that i want to measure but
this is too low you can see there are
areas that are not selected here that's
much better
although maybe it's over selected a bit
and here it's way too high so I've over
thresholded now with our celeste imaging
software has the smart segmentation
where you can actually train it over the
course of just a few seconds to a minute
to detect only the regions of interest
and subtract out the regions of
non-interest so you can see this is very
nice
actin detection with our smart
segmentation whatever you do segmenting
yourself actually let me go back
the Celeste software has a
lot of different capabilities beyond
just measuring intensities you can even
do like 3d visualization or you can
count cells with it or do a parent/child
analysis or look at cell migration over
time there's a lot of different uses
that I'm not going to go into all the
functionalities of Celeste software here
okay and then finally I want to just say
a few words about imaging ethics and
this is something that's not touched
upon enough out there what can you and
can't you do to your images first off
never add anything to your image except
maybe annotations you want your data to
be very honest if you do do any
post-acquisition manipulations there are
some very important points to keep in
mind okay so don't add anything to your
image except annotations don't
selectively enhance one area without
performing the same manipulation on the
whole image don't compare two images
that have not undergone the same
post-acquisition manipulation so you
don't want to brighten one image and dim
another and compare them because that
would just be false data and don't crop
your images in any way that would remove
valid relevant data and if you do crop
it just make sure to you know do that to
other comparable images as well for
instance if you're focusing only on one
area whatever changes you make make sure
that it's reflected in the text of your
paper or even in the captions of the
image always remember ethical imaging
means trustworthy data and replicable
data okay and then finally these last
two slides are just some great links
that you can go to if you want to come
back to this presentation later we have
a number of different
immunohistochemistry and histology and
immuno Saito chemistry pages and
articles on our webpage and here are
many of them that third one there is the
this webinar
specific to this webinar the five steps
to publication quality images and then
finally there's some other useful web
resources I mentioned the spectra viewer
for instance but we also have floor for
selection guide our molecular probes
school of fluorescence that talks about
a lot of the basics of imaging that's a
really great page I highly recommend
that anyone starting out or undergrads
or even if you just want some refreshers
go to the school of fluorescence to get
some great tips
okay so I'll open up for any questions
that you may have
thank you Jason for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
Jason our first question is what is the
difference between immunofluorescence
immunohistochemistry and in your nose
phytochemistry are these terms
interchangeable well sometimes people
use one for the other but technically
speaking immunohistochemistry deals with
immuno labeling of tissues immuno Saito
chemistry deals with immuno labeling of
cells and culture and both of which fall
under the general umbrella of
immunofluorescence sometimes you'll see
them abbreviated as I F or I HC or ICC
and used interchangeably even on our
webpages but often one that's good for
immunohistochemistry is also good for
immuno Saito chemistry
Sookie Jason our next question now it
seems to be a lot of different
permeabilization detergent in immuno
protocols triton x-100 between 20
saponin and p 40 and a couple others now
how do i choose between them
that's a good question the most common
detergents that are used for immuno
protocols are non ionic detergents
especially triton x-100 but also tween
20 NP 40 or non idaite p 40 as it's also
known as also used sometimes these are
pretty strong detergents that poke holes
in the membranes but they're strong
enough that they can also extract
proteins associated with the membranes
for most immuno Saito chemistry and
histochem astray those are the most
typically used because you really want
to make some big holes there for these
large antibodies to enter but this can
be a problem especially for those
membrane bound proteins if you're trying
to detect for instance surface antigens
on cells and in those cases you might
want to use a gentler detergent saponin
for instance which is named from support
a plant it's a plant derived detergent
actually interacts with membrane
cholesterol selectively removing them
and leaving smaller holes in the
membrane often saponin is used for flow
cytometry and then there's some others
like digit onin for instance that are
even gentler but generally speaking
Triton is probably the most popular
Thank You Jason and that brings me to
this next question that we've received
several from several attendees now what
do you recommend for cleaning objectives
detergent ethanol
when you want when you discover that
there's some debris or something on your
objectives first you want to sort of
spritz it off with a little air can if
it's actual debris that's stuck on the
lens such as dirt of some sort then the
next step is to use a gentle detergent
there's a common one called sparkle out
there it's pink colored but each of the
microscope companies also sell
detergents and what you'll do is you'll
use a lint-free lens paper and a
cotton-tipped applicator you'll put a
drop of that detergent on and use the
lens paper and the cotton tipped
applicator on top of the lens paper to
roll that paper across and absorb off
the detergent with just a little bit of
force from the cotton-tipped applicator
and some slice circular motion and this
will remove most of the debris that may
be on there still in some cases though
that debris doesn't come off with a
gentle detergent immersion oil for
instance is very difficult to get off in
those cases you can go with ethanol
which is a gentler solvent or
isopropanol to put a drop on there and
again remove with clean lens paper you
don't want to use really strong solvents
like for instance chloroform or acetone
unless you absolutely positively have to
because those stronger solvents can
degrade the glue around the lenses
thank you Jason in the interest of time
this will have to be our last question
but I want to remind our audience that
any questions submitted during the
presentation that were not answered out
loud Jason will be answering them via
email following the presentation now
Jason we have a viewer inmate their city
mate after they mounted their slide they
found that there were bubbles under the
coverslip
what can they do or what can he do to
get rid of them that's a good question
bubbles can come from several sources
they can come when you're actually
dropping the mounting solution down on
to your sample
sometimes bubbles will come out of your
dropper other times there can be air
trapped inside the tissue and when the
mountains cures or hardens it'll
compress the tissue forcing the air out
of that tissue usually if it's from the
tissue it's very tiny bubbles that
appear only over the tissue whereas if
it's air droplets that come out during
the deposition of the mountain they're
usually larger and off and off off the
tissue section if you're using an
aqueous based Mountain like our
prolonged products you can remove the
cover slip by putting the slide into
warm PBS solution maybe at 37 degrees
with a little bit of movement and it
slowly dissolves away the prolong and
the cover slip will slide off and at
that point you've lost the air bubbles
and you can remount the sample with some
new prolong if you're mounting us in a
solvent based mountain though you have
to actually use solvents to remove the
mounting medium and it's not always
successful and can cause damage to your
tissue also that's another reason to use
an aqueous based mountain
thank you again Jason now before we go
I'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions and a quick
reminder that the questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration I would also like to thank
Bob Rose and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through October 2018
Bob routes will alert you via email when
this is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
thanks for joining us goodbye